[Música]
[Aplausos]
en mí
y la mente tuyo es imposible amarte más
eres tú mi eternidad
y en fin
[Música]
finalmente tú no es imposible amarte más
eres tú mi eternidad
infinitamente
de tu yo es imposible amarte más eres
una eternidad
y fini
mírame
[Música]
yo
es imposible amarte más
eres tú mi eternidad
y
y también
[Música]
es imposible amarte más
eres tú mi eternidad
[Música]
en fin
m
[Música]
es imposible amarte más
eres tú mi eternidad
hola buenas tardes bueno esto que
escucharon es realmente cómo se va
formando armónicamente una pieza una
pieza que originalmente era una sola voz
se convirtió en una pieza a siete voces
todo eso retumba en mi cabeza y bueno lo
tengo que sacar de alguna manera bueno
me presento yo soy rain re lobo soy
cantante soy músico de nacimiento músico
de profesión músico de 24 horas músico
de todos los días no sé hacer otra cosa
más que música música música y carne
asada
soy músico de nacimiento soy músico de
toda la vida soy director de orquesta
soy director vocal me encanta la cocina
me encanta cocinar me encanta me encanta
soy
acereros de pittsburgh de corazón desde
hace muchos años desde los 10 años hace
ya varios
soy fanático del fútbol americano lo
disfruto mucho mucho mucho mucho me
gusta mucho ver la televisión y me acabo
de ser fanático de algo bien padre
así
bueno mi nombre es earl bay
yo la verdad empecé en esto de de la
cantada
cuando entrara a la carrera antes de eso
pues toda mi vida había sido fútbol
fútbol fútbol jugar fútbol por fútbol
por obvias razones soy enfermo loco
fanático de los tigres demasiado enfermo
tengo 25 años soy el más chico del grupo
entonces de ahí para arriba los demás
les vayan calculando gente
algo mío pues la verdad no me gusta la
boca te lo tengo que confesar no todos
lo sabían pero para que sepan no me
gusta la barca te lo odio con todo mi
ser este y también soy muy fanático de
game otros
hola buenas tardes mi nombre es alberto
y yo soy el más guapo del grupo porque
una vez estamos en un concierto y una
tía grito benítez el mango
no le puedo decir que no a mi tía
entonces yo sea el más guapo del grupo
yo soy diseñador gráfico empecé primero
siendo bailarín y terminé siendo
cantante
a mí también
carga el aguacate lo odio
yo no soy fanático de los tigres de lo
que sí soy muy fanático de gignac así
que si en algún momento de este vídeo de
youtube
una llamada
de lo que sí soy muy fanático así
enfermo mal plan soy de coldplay me
encanta coldplay vivo por world play
tengo un tatuaje de coldplay entonces
existo en muy mal y también soy muy
fanático de gay mostró también me gusta
mucho
hola que tal como están yo soy bruno
sungard soy actor soy director de teatro
licenciado en merca
y bueno que a mí a mí sí me gusta el
aguacate
soy un fanático de las películas
catastróficas me encantan las películas
del fin del mundo este se acabó la
humanidad no hay esperanza nada más que
uno
me encanta y me encanta todo lo que
tiene que ver con zombies
me encanta the walking dead the walking
dead
me fascina
y también bueno desde que supe que había
unos zombies en el bronx congelado pero
había unos zombies
me volví muy fanático de game of thrones
no tuve otra winter is coming viene lo
mejor
hola yo soy kevin soy diseñador gráfico
y la verdad me encanta ser diseñador
gráfico yo la verdad es de muy chico
empecé a cantar desde que estaba muy muy
muy chiquito la verdad aprovechaba y
cuando concurso de canto se me
atravesaba pues vaya a formarme nuevo
bien
visto este yo a los 14 años decidí que
quería tocar el bajo y alguien me cosa
es que aprendo que la guitarra primero y
desde entonces soy guitarrista
nunca aprendí a tocar abajo
y desde entonces también soy muy fan de
john mayer es como mi máximo ídolo mi
artista favorito a mí también me gusta
el aguacate también soy tigre
y soy muy muy fan de game of thrones
hola yo soy luis estudié administración
de empresas pero me dedico a ser maestro
de yoga desde hace ya tiempo han
escuchado alguno que otro estereotipo de
los maestros de yoga
y casi todo son ciertos y no como gluten
no como azúcar refinada y nunca pido
popote en los restaurantes hay que
cuidar el medio ambiente
me gusta mucho leer leí todos los libros
publicados de que mostramos
en intenso y aunque la serie no es muy
muy fiel a los libros también soy fan
hola qué tal yo soy juan soy ingeniero
de tecnologías computacionales médico la
programación y antes que pregunten no no
sé de hackear facebook
soy una mezcla rara entre constructor de
páginas web e intento de maestro pokemon
soy que invierte corazón y a pesar que
soy muy bueno me gusta jugar mucho los
videojuegos es estresante llegué aquí a
monterrey del 2008
vengo hacia victoria tamaulipas siendo
la oveja negra de mi familia porque no
me quise quedar en la ciudad a dedicarme
a la docencia como todos y al parecer
aquí sigo siendo la oveja negra literal
porque soy el único que no venimos
bromas
[Música]
pero bueno eso está bien de hecho eso lo
caracteriza nosotros como grupo nuestras
diferencias son las que nos unen
nosotros somos
imagínense
siete personalidades diferentes siete
gustos diferentes siete humores
diferentes siete características
diferentes siete cabezas diferentes
siete todos diferentes todos diferentes
todos diferentes y teníamos que
encontrar algo una estructura una
estructura bien pensada bien planeada
algo que nos llevará a un lugar a un
punto en común algo que compartiéramos
todos la verdad encontramos ese punto en
cantar cada vez que estamos juntos cada
vez que podemos cada vez que nos vemos
hacemos esto hacemos esto cantar cantar
a todos nos gusta todo nos apasiona es
como un objetivo en la vida de cada uno
a final de cuentas nos encontramos en
algún lugar si no era en el aguacate era
en
y bueno fue cantando ahí fue donde nos
encontramos los 77 notas diferentes 7
espectros 7 sonidos diferentes
hermanados en un fin que era un solo
sonido y bueno me gustaría que ya que
estamos en esto cada uno de mis
compañeros dijera
que siente el proceder lo que significa
hacer éter
para mí éter es el producto de meses y
meses de sacrificio de
paciencia disciplina entrega y sobre
todo pasión por esto que es el arte de
la música el resultado el cual me siento
muy orgulloso de formar parte
me gusta cantar como está claro verdad y
todo el mundo puede cantar sólo cantar
solo relativamente fácil lo puedes hacer
en la regadera en el carro
no puedes hacer donde sea pero cantar
con seis voces diferentes a la mía y que
entre todos sea un solo sonido armónico
es un reto y me gustan los retos en
parte por eso estoy aquí pero sobre todo
estoy aquí porque yo louis siento que
pertenezco a algo yo luis pertenezco
a todo esto
para mí lo que significa estar en el
éter es estar en un grupo que rompe
paradigmas que nos sigue un estereotipo
establecido porque claramente no somos
la típica boy band
eso para mí se me hace muy enriquecedor
estar en un grupo en el que no seguimos
una regla y en
pues prácticamente nos vale madre las
reglas y hacemos lo que nosotros nos
gusta
bueno eso de que no somos una boy band
típica no era chiste se rieron está bien
lo vamos a tomar como un cumplido
completamente un cumplido pues a mí la
verdad para mí hacer es seguir un sueño
y poder compartirlo con todos porque
porque siempre fue para mí un sueño
cantar y nunca he renunciado a él y
también compartir el escenario o un
momento para crear música juntos con
otras seis personas que admiro y que
respeto muchísimo entonces para mí eso
es seguir un sueño etcétera
por mí
este eres todo un viaje la verdad ha
sido un viaje que hemos emprendido
juntos en el que hemos encontrado
momentos felices momentos no tantos
hemos encontrado baches en el camino
pero al final aquí estamos los 727
juntos es un viaje que hemos que hemos
llevado llevado juntos hemos crecido
como profesionales hemos crecido como
compañeros pero personalmente siempre
que hemos crecido mucho como personas
entonces toda esta diversidad nos ha
enriquecido mucho a cada uno de nosotros
bueno pues para mí este es un resumen
son dos cosas muy importantes una
es tener esto que es la música y el
cantar que prácticamente digo yo sé que
mis compañeros van a compartir esto pero
el cantar y la música me define
totalmente este se ha convertido en
en medio de todos los días
y lo segundo sería el hecho de como en
individuos antes de conocernos y de
trabajar juntos ya tomamos riesgos y
hacíamos locuras en este mundo de la
música y del canto y el hecho de
juntarnos a hacer esas locuras y
aceptarlas y estar emocionados por
hacerlas eso para mí es verdad
definitivamente no tiene precio
hace tres años que nace éter
un sonido que trae ya yo revuelto en la
cabeza
de buscar no precisamente al
a las voces por tesituras que si son
tenores barítonos sino los sonidos a los
timbres los timbres en la voz es como la
huella digital es único cada uno de los
timbres es único
podemos tener tres cuatro tenores pero
suenan diferentes nos van a dar una
textura diferente y en mi cabeza
rebotaba algo así no sabía que era
intenté primero con 12
intenté con 10 y la realidad es que el
sonido quedaba en 7 entonces cuando a mí
me preguntan que es que es éter
para mí esto es él
no hay otro sonido yo no puedo sacar
alberto y meter a alguien más
porque el timbre que va es es el de
armas es el más bonito y el más guapo
bueno realmente queremos dejar aquí como
testimonio o algo compartirles
cuando estén en un equipo de trabajo y
tengan 10 personas diferentes opinando
qué maravilla que no les dé miedo que no
les dé miedo que sean todos con ideas
diferentes todos con ideologías
diferentes todos con gustos diferentes
si van a un solo fin
el final del viene el objetivo sean
claros hacia dónde van que no les
importa las decisiones de cada uno
porque ojo de repente algunos del equipo
va a tener una idea maravillosa y esa
marca idea maravillosa es la que va
el objetivo al que iban y el logro no es
de él
el logro es de todos y tenemos que
aprender como equipo de trabajo a que si
a alguien le sale bien algo aplaudir se
lo si el canta bonito un día en un
concierto y todos se lo pedimos si
alguien hace algo bueno en el ensayo
todo se lo pedimos ustedes aplaudan el
logro de sus compañeros recuerden el
logro de cada uno es la suma de los
éxitos de cada uno de ustedes
de todo el grupo
que no se les olvide que todos van en el
mismo barco entonces son importantes
como individuos
es lo que va a marcar la pauta
nosotros somos 71
quería compartir con ustedes ahora sí
toda la canción infinitamente tuyo que
es nuestro primer sencillo
[Música]
más
y ahora
[Música]
sí
el 5
además
[Música]
[Aplausos]